وفي ردود الفعل قال المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جون كيربي
قال ان السعوديين ابلغوا واشنطن
باتصالاتهم مع الايرانيين لكن لم يكن
للولايات المتحده دور في الاتفاقيه واكد
كربي ان ما يهم واشنطن وانهاء الحرب في
اليمن واقف الهجمات على السعوديه مشددا
على ان الولايات المتحده سترى ما اذا كانت
ايران ستفي بالتزاماتها بعد ابرامها
الاتفاقيه مع السعوديه واضاف انه ليس
واضحا ما اذا كانت الاتفاقيه السعوديه مع
ايران ستؤثر على اتفاقيات ابرهم
وفي رد على سؤال عن موقفه من استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران
قضى رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان العلاقات
الافضل بين اسرائيل وجيرانها العرب يعد
امرا افضل للجميع
ما كانت العلاقات افضل بين اسرائيل
وجيرانها العرب كان ذلك افضل للجميع
هذا وقد دعرب رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الرفاني
عن ترحيب دوله قطر بالبيان السعوديه
الايراني الصيني وجاء ذلك في اتصال مع
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان وافادت وكاله الانباء القطريه ان
رئيس مجلس الوزراء اسيرا الخارجيه القطري
اعرب كذلك عن تطلع بلاده الى ان تساهم هذه
الخطوه في تعزيز الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه بما يعود بالمنفعه على جميع
شعوبها من ناحيه اخرى قالتها الخارجيه
الايرانيه ان الرئيس مجلس الوزراء ازيرا
الخارجيه القطري هنا وزير الخارجيه
الايراني على التواصل الاتفاق لاستعاده
العلاقات بين ايران والسعوديه ووفق وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه فقد تحدث الطرفان في
الاتصال الهاتفي عن الغاء العقوبات وضروره
الاهتمام الانساني بتبادل الاسرى بين
ايران
والولايات المتحده كما عرب وزير الخارجيه
الايراني عن تهنئته للشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الالفاني على توليه رئاسه الوزراء
في دوله قطر
رحبت سلطنه عمان بالبيان المشترك باستئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه السعوديه الايرانيه
وعربت الخارجيه العمانيه عن عملها في ان
يساهم استئناف العلاقات بين السعوديه
وايران في تعزيز ركائز الامن والاستقرار
في المنطقه